i saw a tweet over the weekend you know
i was thinking about this psycho some
people had issue with the word psychosis
call it what you want okay it's crazy
and i see this grown man on twitter this
went viral
and his name is amir ataran
he's a professor um
if we look at his bio i have to see it
said professor he's a professor whatever
that means
calls himself a scientist too
um if you look at his bio the only thing
that's missing is he him i'm not kidding
but there's people who you could just
you just know there's a type out there
right professor litergator scientist
bicyclist husband father son wrecks
grifters anti-vaxxers and scientific
illiterates
so am i right the only thing that's not
that's missing he him you know woke
right and by that i mean that he has to
let everybody know that he's part of
he's part of the club he speaks the
special he speaks the language
he speaks also like maybe donate money
to ukraine ukrainian flag in there
something there's a few woe causes
missing i don't know amir you gotta you
gotta update that bio it's not
sufficient
anyway he went on a rampage
and he went after there was a united
flight he was on this is what he writes
hey at united why are you breaking the
law masks are required on all flights
out of canada your flight attendant
isn't wearing one took photos of the
poor woman and posted them this is ua
3737 in ottawa right now goes on this
went on it really i mean it read like a
really angry child
uh canada is not the usa you [ __ ]
he got into like
i mean isn't that probably what he
sounded like you know
i can imagine him saying it out loud
then typing it in getting real in
chicago now then he says he had a
friendly conversation with the flight
attendant and found out she's blameless
oh you found out later
after you posted her picture all over
the internet and you know god knows what
kind of harassment that led to then you
then you found out oh it wasn't really
her fault delayed and put it in the
thread
okay all right
he goes on united should be forbidden
flying to canada immediately our country
are rules
bunch of yankees mad about this and
trying to ratio have fun all caps i love
all caps added effect don't like
canada's laws then keep your american
companies in your own country it goes on
i mean it went on
and on
and oh and if you republican reptiles
alliteration
dislike canada's coveted safety laws
you'll totally hate our gun safety laws
yeah actually i do thanks for asking
anyway this went on and on and on this
is someone who
i don't know something's not something's
not all there up top if you know what i
mean you're grown man
you're a grown man grown man and you're
doing this
is there not some hobby on the side that
you could be doing instead i mean this
was insane and i have to go to tyler
please before i i don't know if i can
keep it together guys i'm gonna try
christina pusha who works for governor
desantis found this
she has a tweet she found a picture of
him
he wears this on a plane but he doesn't
think it protects him so everyone else
has to play along with his delusions and
there is a photo of him a tweet of him
and this is what he says another flight
on an american
mask free airline another day for the
p100 mask
it's actually more comfortable than an
n95 tyler i don't know if you have that
one
shows him and it looks like he's in a
respirator mask
this is how he gets on the airplane
okay so listen
there's a lot of crazy out there i
understand this is crazy you get on an
airplane a respirator mask you haven't
read the studies on math look at the
picture that's how he gets on the
airplane and the problem was with the
flight attendant okay kiddo
we're the problem you got on a plane
like that
and i'm the problem
okay
i really hope that there's more of a
percentage of our audience that sides
with me on this because if you all think
it's normal to get on an airplane read
the studies on masks
read the studies on masks truly
i'm sure he's vast and three times
boosted too
i would it would i would be very
surprised if he came out was like and
i'm unvaccinated no you know he lined up
for that booster he's been fouchified
he's been fouchified
so this is what i'm saying though right
this is this is not healthy this is not
healthy one because now listen you want
to you want to get on a plane like that
with your mask your respirator mask or
whatever it is you i don't care if you
want to put on the outfit that the guy
wore an outbreak you see that movie
outbreak head to toe hazmat i don't care
if you want to wear that to get on a
plane your prerogative pay for it have
fun
the problem is is that he shamed
somebody else just a normal woman who
probably realized
okay i'm just going to live my life i'm
going to be a normal person not going to
be crazy he shamed her and he went on a
rampage that exposed him as a
four-year-old
so my point is you see this is the type
of psychosis that has the potential to
spread to a child
and then a child who would be pretty
normal in life just going about his
business who is not at risk of severe
disease disease when it comes to covid
he's children are not at risk buy buy
buy and launch the numbers are so
minuscule and the comorbidities have to
be so high for a child to be at risk
your average child is not at risk from
covet end of story but that kid will now
live in fear oh my god that person
doesn't have a math oh my gosh my friend
didn't get the vaccine oh my god okay
this person has the capacity to spread
that to a child and ripple out into a
population that does not need to be
growing up bearing the burden of adult
neuroses
okay
so i pointed that out because i also
need to get a segment in here like dummy
of the week
that would have been a home run by the
way
what's the male version of a karen
i know right is it now is it
that's beyond karen i didn't see a karen
in a respirator mask on an airplane i
don't know
this guy's a professor yeah
well that he molds young minds exactly
i'm gonna get the anti-vaxxers
what do you care if you let me ask you
though you got the vaccine
you got the vaccine and you have the
respirator mask and still that's not
enough
you're still not protected enough right
so maybe you should call up
pfizer and say your shot doesn't work
well enough because i got my six
vaccines and i have my mask on and i
still don't feel safe because somebody
across the hall just coughed
okay well and props to twitter twitter
for ratioing the guy like even they were
like dude you're a joke like you're kind
of an embarrassment and like he just
loses his mind man
canada is not the us canada is not the
u.s
we take your guns away in canada and
leave you helpless also you can't get on
an airplane without respirator met
that's not exactly an advertisement for
canada you may think so what's his name
amir amir amir
professor and he's like i'll challenge
anyone to a debate okay i got somebody
i'm not gonna do it i'm not a scientist
but i have some that would oh that would
be like their lunch
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]